ahora vamos a ver la segunda forma más
utilizada para hacer análisis de
circuitos se llama método de corrientes
de malla es una de mis favoritas hay un
punto en este método donde nos
inventamos por aquí unas corrientes que
están fluyendo en círculos y la verdad
está muy interesante ahora en el método
de corrientes de malla lo que hacemos es
definir corrientes de malla así es que
vamos a empezar definiendo este concepto
corrientes de malla una corriente de
malla es una corriente que fluye en una
malla y la malla son como estas ventanas
en medio del circuito
esta es una malla de nuestro circuito
esta es otra malla de nuestro circuito y
bueno esta también es una malla de
nuestro circuito esta va a ser nuestra
corriente de malla número 1 y le vamos a
llamar a 1 y también podemos ponerle el
nombre a estas otras corrientes de malla
y dos las estoy definiendo a todas estas
corrientes de malla de la misma forma
fluyendo como las manecillas del reloj
claro que aquí nos vamos a detener un
segundo para ponerle nombre a todos los
demás componentes de nuestro circuito a
este le vamos a llamar ve este es r1 r2
r3
r 4 y a esta fuente de corriente le
vamos a llamar y lo que tenemos aquí
esta fuente de corriente lo cual hace
que este circuito se vuelva mucho más
interesante y de hecho es por esto que
estamos utilizando el método de
corrientes de malla la palabra malla de
hecho viene de los mosquiteros que
podemos tener en una puerta o en una
ventana y son como un alambrado y en
medio de esos alambres tenemos estas
como ventanitas pequeñas a las que les
llamamos malla y como tiene una
estructura similar adoptamos el nombre
en fin estas corrientes de malla son
súper interesantes porque en cierto
sentido si existen aunque no parezca que
realmente lo hacen porque como pueden
estas corrientes están fluyendo en
círculos pero veámoslo con un poco más
de detalle por aquí la corriente que
fluye a través de la fuente de voltaje
es igual a la corriente de malla y uno y
luego por aquí la corriente de malla y
uno
está fluyendo a través del resistor r1
ahora qué pasa cuando llegamos al
resistor r2 bueno pues esta la corriente
de malla y uno que fluye hacia abajo
pero también está la corriente de malla
y 2 que fluye hacia arriba y esto como
puede tener sentido bueno pues lo que
vamos a hacer es dibujar a r2 por acá
este es el resistor r2 tenemos por aquí
la corriente de malla y uno fluyendo
hacia abajo y la corriente de malla y
dos fluyendo hacia arriba también voy a
dibujar la corriente que fluye por el
resistor r2 la corriente de elemento y
r2 y lo que va a suceder por cierto es
una aplicación maravillosa del principio
de superposición y uno
y se superponen en el resistor r2 y
producen y r2 entonces si nosotros
quisiéramos conocer y r2 es la suma de
estas dos corrientes de malla ahora y
uno está fluyendo en la misma dirección
que r2 entonces podemos poner por aquí y
10 y 2 está fluyendo en la dirección
contraria por lo cual le ponemos un
signo menos y 2 y si por alguna razón
conocemos y 1 y 2 así es como calculamos
la corriente y r2 la corriente de
elemento que está fluyendo a través del
resistor r2 ahora como este es un método
pues vamos a escribir todo paso por paso
el paso número 1 es dibujar todas las
mallas
hicimos esto cuando dibujamos estas
corrientes de malla y 1 y 2 y 3
el paso número 2 es resolver las fáciles
ya qué nos referimos con esto bueno pues
por ejemplo aquí tenemos un ejemplo de
una fácil porque la fuente de corriente
y define cuál es la corriente de malla y
3 así es que ib3 es un ejemplo de una
corriente de malla fácil de resolver y
luego el tercer paso en el método de
corrientes de malla es escribir la ley
de voltaje de kirch off y escribir la
ley de voltaje de kirchhoff para las dos
corrientes de malla restantes y el
cuarto paso es resolver en este vídeo
vamos a hacer los tres primeros pasos y
en el próximo vídeo vamos a terminar de
resolverlo así es que utilicemos este
método de corrientes de malla paso
número 1 dibujar las mallas ya las
tenemos por aquí este es el paso número
uno en estas tres mallas dibujadas por
acá así es que ya podemos decir que ya
hicimos el paso 1
paso número 2 resolver las fáciles y 3
es uno de los fáciles y tres fluye hacia
abajo a través de la fuente de corriente
entonces aquí estamos en el paso número
dos y sabemos que y 3 es igual a menos
porque está influyendo en direcciones
opuestas y listo ya terminamos con el
paso 2 esta fue la corriente de malla
fácil de resolver entonces vamos al paso
número 3 escribir la ley de voltajes de
kerchove para cada una de estas mallas
vamos a empezar por aquí le vamos a dar
la vuelta a toda esta malla escribiendo
la ley de voltaje de kirchhoff así es
que empezamos por aquí le damos la
vuelta lo primero con lo que nos
encontramos es un aumento de voltaje
entramos por el lado negativo y salimos
por el lado positivo entonces este es un
aumento de voltaje
dv volts luego vamos a través del
resistor r1 que tiene una corriente de
malla y uno fluyendo a través de él y
tiene un voltaje así porque la corriente
está fluyendo en esta dirección así es
que vamos a tener una caída de voltaje
de caída de voltaje
r 1 por y 1 entonces ahorita estamos
aquí pasamos por la esquina y llegamos a
r2 pero ahora
r2 no es tan sencillo porque aquí
tenemos y uno fluyendo en esta dirección
pero también y dos fluyendo en la
contraria entonces qué vamos a hacer
aquí bueno pues empecemos con lo que
tenemos ya encontramos que esta
corriente fluyendo por aquí se escribe
de esta forma lo tenemos aquí pero bueno
a este resistor le ponemos un más por
acá y un menos por aquí vamos a tener
otra caída de voltaje ponemos un menos r
2 r2 por la corriente a través del
resistor pero esa es igual a y uno menos
y 2
y ya terminamos con este lazo ya
recorrimos todos estos elementos y ahora
simplemente regresamos al punto de
inicio y entonces esta es nuestra
ecuación de la ley de voltaje de
kirchhoff por lo que esto tiene que ser
igual a cero y ahora vamos con esta otra
malla empezamos por aquí y la recorremos
en este sentido entonces empezamos por
aquí llegamos al resistor r2 y como lo
recorremos de menos a más
entonces es un aumento de voltaje por lo
que ponemos un más aquí ahora este
voltaje es exactamente el mismo término
que tenemos por aquí la resistencia 2 x
1 - y 2 ok
ese es el voltaje de aquí para acá pero
el resistor r3 tiene una sola corriente
de malla que es y 2 entonces podemos
poner por aquí un signo + y - y la
corriente que pasa por aquí tiene una
caída de voltaje por lo que tenemos un
menos y el voltaje de aquí para acá es r
y 2
2 luego llegamos a r 4 y aquí tenemos
exactamente el mismo asunto que teníamos
por acá a través de este resistor fluyen
dos corrientes de malla entonces vamos a
hacer lo mismo vamos a definir esto como
una caída de voltaje en este sentido
aquí está la corriente del elemento en
este sentido y así tiene la misma forma
que lo que teníamos por acá entonces si
estamos por aquí fluyendo en esta malla
tenemos una caída de voltaje por lo que
ponemos un signo menos y el voltaje en
el resistor r4 es r 4 por la corriente a
través del resistor pero en este caso es
2 que fluye hacia abajo
- y 3 que fluye hacia arriba y 3 y luego
regresamos al punto de inicio y ya
terminamos entonces la ley de voltajes
de kirchhoff nos dice que todo esto
tiene que ser igual a cero así es que
estas son nuestras dos ecuaciones
simultáneas que obtuvimos con el método
de corrientes de malla escribiendo las
leyes de voltajes de kirchhoff así es
que ya podemos ponerle una palomita al
paso 3 y únicamente nos falta resolver
estas ecuaciones que es lo que vamos a
hacer en el próximo vídeo